the Joe Rogan experience let me get this
out
I want to talk about that that Netflix
show don't [ __ ] with cats I keep
forgetting it
don't [ __ ] with cats this was a rule
number one that they told me when I
moved from Cuba threw a rock at the cat
one man a black guy go yo I'm [ __ ] with
them [ __ ] some dude on the
internet decided to [ __ ] with cats and
have you watch the doctor series no it's
gonna blow your mind it's gonna blow
your mind
it's a Netflix that likes 10 episode
documentary had something you gonna call
dogs cats what did you get me involved
in Jodie's
it's called don't [ __ ] with don't [ __ ]
with cats I think it's like three
episodes I watched two of them last
night actually like a bit yeah it's like
remember the old school Internet [ __ ]
from the early 2000s where there's weird
[ __ ] online yeah people were discovering
who the [ __ ] was doing some of that and
like fall they fell down some [ __ ]
weird holes Oh crazy yeah yeah
disturbing is [ __ ] is it three episodes
because I think I have I believe so yeah
watch three yeah yeah I thought it was
more than it's called don't [ __ ] with
cap don't [ __ ] yeah that's it that's it
don't this is how the party starts oh my
god tremendous and you know wolf is on
TV last week the reason why I called you
but I didn't want to tell you until
afterward I wanted to talk to you about
on the show i boy made it come back he
ain't gonna lie he got another week and
a half left to live
whoo Michael Bowden made a comeback
because of the abstain family Michael
badan badan yeah the Epstein family oh
yeah yeah I did
okay that's my boy yeah boy survived
that show you and me both oh my god I
should remember having conversations
about with you about saying you can't
commit a crime with that guy around
drugs too good because once he gets
aren't the most memorable thing he ever
busted was you ready for this G he found
they found the torso in New Jersey it
belonged to a woman the guy did a great
job
he caught a waist he got her arms her
head
and he threw a whole body into the ocean
that sharks got everything except the
torso torso just washed up in the
seaside I to some Jersey Shore town you
remember this episode I've been kinda
I'm gonna and she [ __ ] had fake tits
so that's her serial numbers from the
tits I found out who she was but none oh
it gets better
he went deep into the murky waters he
also went into his stomach and the food
that she had eaten had been processed so
there were a certain clam it was a
certain type of clam that couldn't be
found it wasn't there and it couldn't
either been Boston and New Jersey I'm
not putting the blame on though right
right I remember this so he too found
out her whereabouts and he found that he
called like every restaurant on that
area to see who would have that specific
type of clam hmm and he [ __ ] caught
the killer because he paid for with his
credit card whoa so he went and found
that the specific clam what restaurant
in that area sold it and that's what she
had enough stomach
they weren't cherry stones or the other
ones they were the other ones there was
the most horrific story from that one
one episode where they had this guy
believe he was a doctor and he was
infatuated with this woman who was his
patient and when she died he I think he
had married her one time down or
something like that he it's some kind of
relationship with her he'd dug up her
body and kept it in his house and it put
a tube where her vagina is so he could
still have sex with her and he was
buying cases and cases of perfume and I
think that's what tip people off this
guy was buying cases of perfume because
she was rotting in his bed so he would
cover her with perfume showy autopsy
autop HBO autopsy yeah [ __ ] great
show great show and they would come on
like at 1:00 so he studies Jeffrey
Epstein and he finds out that there's
breaks and Jeffrey Epstein's neck that
is he's never seen ever in a hanging and
only seen from strangulation only see
four murders
you know they said that he hung himself
yeah am i [ __ ] am I only one that's
missing this they're trying to find it's
a four-foot wall yeah he threw himself
against the wall mm-hmm went down was
really right the the neck had blood but
the [ __ ] thing then that blood on it
it's such a horrible [ __ ] thing yeah
the cops the overtime they had been
working the tapes got shut off how about
the fact that they deleted the first
tapes oh so he would he had an original
attempt on his life and then if they had
a second one and they they can't find
the tapes for the second one and then
they accidentally deleted the tapes in
the first one I mean this it's not 1930
it's 2020 if they can get away with that
in 2020 I mean I don't know how far
anyone's gonna track this down how far
like how many they are what they the
reason why he got arrested in the first
place is because people did talk about
it and they did get motivated to do
something because they're like how does
a guy get arrested for having sex with
underage kids and then only get like 13
months and then during that 13 months he
had a baby basically he was like he just
had a return at night right he didn't he
he had the ability to travel and go
wherever he wanted a at 16 hours like
work release for the day could go to his
office do what he did literally all you
do is sleep there every night so was it
an inconvenience an inconvenience for
him and everybody's like what and then
when you start thinking about the
stories and the jet in the island and
all the craziness like this is not a
movie this is real this is not a movie
there was an island where an
intelligence agent would take scientists
and heads of state and they would bang
chicks that intelligence thing is I'll
just say strong rumor because it's only
been mentioned by a few people and like
that ABC report didn't mention it at all
maybe they left it out I don't think
they can prove it so when someone says
something and then that I mean is there
a recording of that guy saying who
remember the guy that said that he was
told that it wasn't that Epstein was
intelligence news above his pay grade
Acosta yes he was his name again I
Shaima I don't know though geologist
Alexander cross to Jim we got fired
though or he had to resign after they
went and looked into this and you got
mmm RIA rested
[Applause]